人類の
ジャンプ力
俺はまだまだいけるんじゃないかと思って
ま。この風向きだと
４２メートル半
まさき取締役）　４２メートル半！？それはすごいですね
まさき取締役）　　鳥もびっくりですね
鳥はびっくりしないです
まぁどんなに苦しいげん....
噛んだ。ごめんもう一回
どんな苦しい環境でも
いつでもお前らは飛べる
I
can
フラァ...
(fly)
ふぅっ・・くしゅん
うぉ!  うわぁ!!
待ってほんとに高い
うゎ、ちょっと
あ！きたきた
あぁあぁ
あぁ待って待ってマジ骨折れた
こんにちわ
もっとも空に近い男はじめしゃちょーです
先ほどみてもらったこれなんですけども
なんか、ジャンピングホパー空気のガスの圧力を使って飛ぶやつです
バネは入ってないんですけどー
中にすごい空気がたまってて
とりあえすバネとちがってもう
空気の圧で圧縮して飛ぶんで、めちゃくちゃ高いです
ジャンピングホッパーの空気ガスバージョンがあります
だが俺はこんなもんじゃ満足しない
これだけでも十分高く飛べると思うんですけど
もっと
今の俺たちができるジャンプ力の限界を目指すため今回はこちら
これやばいぞけっこう
今見てもらったように
かなりジャンプ力が高いです
僕は思った
この空気圧で飛ぶ最強のジャンプホッパー
そして強力なばねを持つトランポリン
このトランポリンを轢いて
そのトランポリンの上にこのジャンプホッパーで勢いをつけてジャンプすると
最強に飛ぶんじゃないか
僕はそう思ったわけです
というわけで今日は
今までジャンプしてきた動画の中では
もっともジャンプ力の高い動画です
待ってやべぇ
俺はこの二つの道具を使って
では、いこう!!
あ!
まさき、怖いよぅ
いきます！！
こう　こう　こう　だよね
まさき取締役）　うん
いきます！
３（スリー）
２（ツー）
１（ワン）
（微笑）
こわよー、たすけてー
まぁー　でも やるしかねぇよな
やりましょう
いきます！
３（スリー）
２（ツー）
１（ワン）
いやいやいやいや
いきます！
３（スリー）
２（ツー）
１（ワン）
うゎ!　ちょっと待って、ほんとにこれ
すいません
うまく飛べません...
なんか、バランスが取れなくてそのまま倒れちゃうんで
ちょっと、一発勝負でやります
ジャンピングホッパーを持ったまま走って
そのまま、僕がジャンプしてトランポリンに乗るんで
その勢いで走った助走もつけつつ
トランポリンの上にジャンピングホッパーをぐっといって
そのままジャンプします
もう、これがラストチャンス
必ず.............飛びます
全国のみんな
お前なら飛べる
I
can
fly
いきます!!
まさき取締役）　はい
３（スリー）
２（ツー）
１（ワン）
まさき取締役）違うよ〜ww
..............................
ジャポーン